you
all right so my name is Robert Clark I'm
co-founder of a little company we call
kinder robotics which is a New York
city-based drone services company so be
prepared the first couple of minutes
will be a little bit of shameless
self-promotion just because we're still
fairly early on what we do is a hardware
is a service we've kind of found that a
lot of the consumer market consumer
dedicated drone companies spend a lot of
their time trying to sell people really
expensive and complex hardware and quite
frankly not everyone is going to buy a
drone because they're just really clever
toys that once you crash them the first
time will just be a dust collection
rather you've got a wife girlfriend or
husband they will look at you with ire
every single time they walk by it
all right so what we do is that we offer
kind of a mobile platform or a read
based platform where you can up one-time
registration paper use specify area of
interest where you want this drone to be
the drone flies there at one on this way
there notifies you say hey I am almost
here what would you like it to do there
are pre-selected mission profiles that
you can choose from some of the more
interesting ones are stop your
girlfriend all right not really good
maybe someone will do that because uh we
kind of see this platform being an open
API where you create the hardware and
create the infrastructure give users it
the ability to create different
applications there are only so many
things that we ourselves can as a
company can think of that might be
clever as use-case but I've seen a lot
of more interesting thoughts come out of
you know just a random public at large
so the drone kind of goes execute the
mission once once it's done it either
puts it the video like a video file
directly to the web browser or to your
mobile app
or it puts it up on YouTube so you can
have the data on demand and once a
missions completed the drone goes back
it's like landing platform charges
itself and waits for the next next
mission and so uh so most drones for me
when I talk drones I really mean
multicopters drones going to really mean
a regular RC aircraft but I usually
think about multicopters specifically uh
you know quad copters hexacopters after
copters and most of them are just a
series of come to rotating fans that you
just use to push right there one of the
simplest simplest air vehicles that
exist because there are no control
surfaces so no brothers no tails no
elevators no flaps it's just a bunch of
fans that just rotate in opposite
directions to push this aircraft and all
six degrees of freedom all right but
that means that the drones are
inherently aerodynamically unstable all
right so you require a fly-by-wire
system where computer is always
constantly updating the system so it has
to be real time with real refresh rates
all right and so this is kind of what a
basic hobbyist
you can go and buy this right now and
the Internet just spend a couple hundred
dollars and this will come to you in a
box and you can fly it around New York
City and crash it into a building and
landing someone and kill them if you so
choose please don't do that because that
makes things really hard for me to start
a company I thought these things happen
um I know a couple of months ago there
was a guy flying one a run off his
Terrace in midtown crashed into a
building near Grand Central and almost
landed in the guy's head but these
things can happen so a basic drone
systems just got an RC transmitter
receiver some sort of autopilot which is
a computer controlling the loop GPS
module battery and all this hardware
stuff all right so my background is in
aerospace and defense so I know all this
hardware stuff but I've been forced to
learn Python because I like all this
drone stuff and so what Python have been
able to do with Python and drones are
being able to use it for really really
interesting acrobatic maneuvers so you
can program mission planning software
rich you can download these off the
internet they're kind of diamond of
dime-a-dozen nowadays you just download
it off the internet and most of it's
written in a C++ but it uses a Python as
a shell and you can program it to
perform mission scripts so you can
specify manually you can specify
waypoints at GPS coordinate locations
and you can have your little drone fly
to these locations and do interesting
things but with Python you can make this
a fully autonomous system right so you
just write a little script and the
Python will run and it will direct your
drone to do all of this up automatically
all right some of the other things I've
done is uh I've used the Python to kind
of expand the number of sensors that you
can have on these open platforms so one
of these drones had come GPS isn't a
very reliable system right so you kind
of need to complement it with other
sensory devices some of the good ones
are sonar optical flow air speed sensors
those are just some of the good things
that you can use Python for and I think
I have an example in here and it
supported up to a Python 2.7 and it's
implemented using ironpython so this is
like a little camera I stole this off of
youtube just so the drone just doesn't
flip in a roll all at the same time and
that's run through a Python script all
right so that's the type of thing you
can do
let's see since this is a Python meeting
I figured I'd talk about some classes
for a second no I said my background is
in hardware so most of this stuff I
leave up to you guys right but uh this
is just how to implement it and you have
the ability to add custom classes like
out I'll get into some of these are
variables later because they're actually
really cool and they actually excite me
because I can use them to do interesting
things right but this is just on the
Python in implementation and it's CEOs
some of the really special commands
right so the curt state variable yes is
one really interesting ones but like the
change mode for people who are not
familiar with drones like you have all
these different flight modes like one of
them in particular is like a loiter
it'll just hold at it at an altitude and
position GPS position and it'll just
wait there right and so you can use a
Python script to put a drone into a
loiter mode from just a standard mission
and it'll just stand there or you can
also put it into a a pattern where
circularly follows a just a it holds a
camera fixed on a pixel a single point
on the ground and it'll just stay there
and it'll fly around in a circle and
keep it fixed on that one point or you
can node lock that to an object on the
ground with some pattern recognition and
if that pattern moves then you can have
the quadcopter the drone follow that
path follow that pattern on the ground
so and that's all done through Python
yeah which is really cool it's really
really cool um so again you know you
wait for word just like you wait for
whatever and then the this difference RC
channel so each each of drone has a
number of control channels that are
receive instructions over control
anything from the different modes and
different motors how they operates what
they're doing at any
the time and so you can just send
commands over those like I said one of
the cool things I use Python for is for
optical flow right so what this doesn't
compensate for compensates for the
vehicles motion while it's in the air so
it measures the change of a physical
feature on the ground right and it
measures its relative X&Y position and
as it moves the new change in pixel
value and I think I have the script for
this in here somewhere but hopefully I
do if not I can show it to you later
and this is all run through Python it's
actually really really interesting
because this is is great for like what
that example I told you you want the you
want your drill and you want your
quadcopter to just stay looking at a
fixed point in space
all right so it'll look it if it moves
because of the wind it'll readjust its
position because it's known where that
physical feature on the ground is moved
and it'll move itself back so that the
pixel values kind of come come for each
other in it it's sensitive enough to
know when it's been a single pixel pixel
motion or whether it's been multiple
pixels right so it'll return a different
value based on how many pixels the
actual phys the actual object has moved
like I said mission scripting like one
of the really cool methods from our
asset variable is like these you can
control pitch the yaw the GPS status
these are just like some of the examples
in the list ISM maybe not this tall but
it's pretty extensive you can monitor
the battery voltage the hell you can
monitor the distance from the home so
these are some of the features and
functions that kind of enable what we're
doing as a company to be able to allow
the drones to figure out where its home
location is how far it's flown how much
battery it's used a lot since to get
from A to B how much calculate how much
battery
to return determine what the wind speeds
are wind directions on all this is done
inside pipeline and that is us kind
robotics that's really what we use
Python for in a day-to-day basis
I said you everyone in the crowd
probably knows the language considerably
better than I do but um it's been a
really boon to our operations and being
able to you know take a technology
that's you just pretty much buy off off
the shelf and be able to do something
really really interesting work with it
if you do actually want to see a copy of
that roll script this is really small
but I've got really great eyes I don't
know about everyone else um but this is
how you execute that our roll I showed
you in the video all right and you just
use some of the classes and the calls
that I've shown earlier and it's
actually pretty simple it's pretty cool
so questions
I feel appreciated now yeah
ooh very very good question yes and
unfortunately yes but no at the same
time so the it does a lot of frequency
hopping but you can GPS spoofer your
copter alright there's actually a guy
who developed a drone stealing copter so
it'll fly wrong and GPS spoof older er
signal and steal your drone and hijack
it for nefarious purposes so that's the
security is actually one the big areas
of concern which we've identified that
needs immediate research because that's
really really big open-ended question
and if you want to see the these types
of systems in the national airspace then
you kind of have to address that so that
it doesn't kill someone
yep so you sort of touch on a bit at the
beginning but what do you think theme so
I guess my question is I think it's cool
that how do I just like the FAA and the
City of York feel about these things
flying around well it's kind of a
catch-22 like this is the technologies
emergent it's coming all right and there
are a lot of applications that can do
real great public good all right but at
the same time you have to balance the
technology with public safety right and
being able to find that that balance is
very critical is very key so right now
the FAA has been charged by Congress to
rewrite the regulations on how you
integrate these systems into the
National aerospace and how you must make
sure that the public is safe and how
they communicate and avoid each other
from crashing other prevented from
colliding into other buildings other
aircraft and but because that because of
the huge potential benefits like they
will they will be coming it is coming
right and and it's not just taco copters
and it's not just and it's not just
Amazon Prime just ok I'm not just
talking about because it's a big it's a
big one but not just not go [ __ ]
from from a drone yeah
so there's actual start up there -
actually there are two startups are
Walden
now there's three then and doing a taco
copter um I don't know how you get it
off the drone maybe it dive-bombs
the taco together maybe it sends you
texting hey your tacos here and they'll
come outside but great so we've got time
for maybe a couple more questions
so this extent
this question actually running a age
restriction on these things
what about overall what regarding a
program deep PreCheck program is the FAA
does have incredibly restrictive
covenants on how high correct your drum
can fly as well as speed which again for
a drone is going to be a big deal for
like say a model jet it's a big job and
how do you guys address that because
some people say well you know what I'm
going to just write this program and I'm
going to have you guys run it and it's
going to do its thing and I can just
tell it's an error
I'm sorry I didn't mean for quite well
JFK and crashed into an aircraft that's
that's a important so part of this
integration process that's happening in
and the discussion that's occurring
right now is identifying one key
technologies that are important to being
able to do what a couple of things are
what we call grumbeigh a sense sense and
avoidance which are key asses that we
will have around the city to put be able
to restrict the aerospace and
communicate with the drones that are you
know up there one of the other ones are
defining dedicated keep out zones and
specifying the rules and regulations for
where and when these things can operate
so right now it's kind of like no-man's
land it's the rules don't really exist
the rules that are coming however are
are kind of incremental there are some
there's plans for some near-term
development and specifying know what
technologies are necessary for this to
be able to operate safely within
national airspace and those those
near-term development goals are going to
kind of be hashed out within the next
one to five years and then there are
midterm goals above okay now that we
have identified the key enabling
technologies and the key enabling
regulations how do we then implement
these into the
to the National aerospace so it's an
incremental process but I think by
partnering with the industry with the
FAA and through industry you know we're
going to kind of get to a point where
it's beneficial for
oh that's well that's kind of like
compression so you yes I have it is on
our development timeline because I am
generally a slave to hardware because
that's my background that's what I'm
familiar with but it is something we've
identified on the development timeline
as we go from building up the business
and going through a proof-of-concept so
know within the next 18 months or so
that's something that we're looking at
second question is then how do you
handle the more computationally
intensive tasks for it for these drones
and one of those is a we are right now I
did find two different things that we
were working on first of which is
whether or not we can take some of the
heavy competition often drone itself and
stick it in the cloud or part of our
that it was an inner part of our
approach are these remotely located
drone landing platforms and stations and
we are looking at taking all the heavy
computation and making the drone itself
as dumb as possible and all it needs to
receiver you know simple high-level
instructions from and having the
charging base or the pod or whatever be
responsible for doing most of the hard
heavy lifting because the more that we
can offload off the drone side the more
capable they are because right now one
the key limitations to the technology
itself is being able to carry its load
carrying capacity because battery
technology just doesn't exist and one of
the unfortunate things that you know jet
diesels or Amazon don't tell people that
the technology to enable these these
systems to be a part of your life
everyday just do not physically exist
yet I thought they're coming all right
but not for a few more years